so the world that we live in continues
to exist in a constant state of change
and my life is no exception to that rule
what I'm trying to say is that I moved
out you guess that already didn't yeah
Casa de Chariman is dead and gone me and
Alex have had our house made divorce now
I managed to keep all of the kids which
makes me very happy he's only gonna see
them on four nights but they love him
more so currently I'm living in house
limbo and waiting to move into my new
flat and while I do that I am staying
here with my girlfriend ah he's got a
girlfriend yeah I do did you did you
seriously think this was my new bed
she's called Emily the same Emily that I
mentioned last week we've been dating
for about six months now it's been going
very very well and I appreciate you not
making a big deal out of it thank you
very much there is something a little
emasculating about sleeping in this bed
and what you can't see is the whole
thing is patterned with many many tiny
little flowers and I think the thing
that all men have to deal with at some
point in their lives is the fact that we
do we do kind of like pretty things
there is no doubt in my mind that I
wouldn't feel comfortable going into a
store and buying pink detergent that
smells like lilies but at the same time
I'm not gonna be complaining about the
fact that I will be smelling delightful
for the next two months now while I'm
staying here I've had to move the
majority of my stuff into storage which
meant hiring a man and van service also
known as the field pathetic and puny
service hereand was nice enough to come
over that day in the hopes that he would
help me move but we spent the majority
of the time just seeing they're watching
a much more capable human do all of the
moving for us and the one time when we
did offer to help out we tried to move a
desk through the doorway and through the
hallway and the movie Go is very much
like you should probably take the legs
off before you do that will make it much
easier but we all I know we can use our
superior intellects to maneuver this
door in a way that will get a surrender
Slee stuck eventually we just had to
bring it back and take the legs off like
you suggested
because he knows best because he moves
stuff for a living not everything that I
own did make it out their house there
was some stuff that I was like you know
I should I should throw this away but
it's a little bit too big and maybe a
little bit too cool to do that so I'm
what I decided to do was hide it in the
Attic so when the next owner finally
does decide to look up there they're
gonna have what I think is a treasure
probe of goodies they're gonna find a
couple of VCR players an obnoxious
electronic nerf gun and a unicycle
remember that unicycle never learned how
to ride that unicycle as a whole the
moving experience has been a mixed bag
to say the least
it's mostly to spin horrendously
stressful but absolutely nothing
compares to the experience of being the
last person to leave the house and
shutting the door knowing that your keys
are still inside it was like leaving a
hotel room and like worrying that you
might have left something in there times
a thousand it was so stressful but also
kind of invigorating I would kind of
recommend moving to anyone just so you
can have that experience once in your
life it's pretty great
so yeah I've moved gonna be him a new
place in a couple of months time and I
have decided to myself then when I move
into the new place after I've settled in
a little bit I'm gonna get a Kim because
Alex never really liked animals and I'm
gonna be living on my own and I'd quite
like a little companion so there you go
that's a change you're excited about
exactly see you later you've just had
the almost imponderable joy of watching
Charlie is so cool like which makes you
like cool okay here's last week's video
in case you missed it it's all about how
I made my second short film offline it
also happens to be the last video ever
to be shot in Casa de Charmin so very
important historical record that
everyone should see at least once in
their lives I promise you'll be telling
your grandkids where you were when you
saw making offline Prague by